in terms of biological significance
carbon is probably the most important
element because it forms a very basis of
life and how is that so it is the
backbone of any known organic molecule
and it forms a building block of protein
and DNA
carbon makes up almost 18 percent of our
body playing such a vital role in all of
its biological functions and
additionally you know that carbon fibers
are used to make nitrate products such
as airplanes and sports equipments
carbon is also a very very critical
element when it comes to Fossil fruits
like coal oil or natural gas tell me in
the comment section down below some more
use cases of this very very important
element
And subscribe